let's bring in to Elton Brand the Sixers
GM pulled off the big deal with Jimmy
Butler Butler is I believe making his
debut tonight in Orlando against the
magic Alton good to have you back on is
that true that Jimmy Butler will make
his debut tonight that is true that's
all I wanted that's all I wanted to talk
to you about so thanks for joining us
here how did you know that Jimmy Butler
was the rice right piece for this team
it was a talent it was his time you know
we'll figure out the rest with the
spacing the shooting but when you can
add a top 16 player you have to take a
shot and you speak to Butler before you
make a deal for Butler no you cannot
speak to him and actually know some
friends of his from Chicago and they're
like hey here's his number but that's
that's against the rules suck and speak
to him direct or his agent did you text
him no okay
I don't want to get in trouble I'm just
curious it's it's kind of strange to be
trading for somebody and could be an
important part of you trying to win a
championship but then did you reach out
to his former teammates can you talk to
them yes oh you did yes yes Michael
Dunleavy Jr Nagi Mohammed all types of
his ex teammates this is to find out
what kind of person he was in the locker
room I'm reading you know different
interviews from home I'm seeing
different interviews on TV about them so
I just want to know what the players
actually felt about him in the locker
room and I mentioned this before you
came on that this is probably a feeling
out period for both of you the team with
Jimmy Butler and Jimmy Butler looking at
the team so it's sort of like you're
dancing here you're not sure if you're
going steady or gonna get engaged
because he can opt out of his contract
so you may be left with nothing so you
you went into this prepared for that
possible scenario yes then absolutely
like that's that's a fair very fair
statement so we hope that he sees a fit
with us and we hope we see a flick with
him but there's nothing binding is he
outside of his contract this summer then
we will have discussions if we both see
a fit but other than that is there's
nothing going for it
who's the team to beat in the East right
now you know Toronto we talked about
them you know Boston I agree with what
you guys are saying when you had me on
hold I think he I think they figure it
out
and don't forget about Milwaukee I
played with Coach Boone and housing he's
a great coach stay out of the talent and
Indiana's right there too so you know
when I had a chance to get this just
level of talent I just felt like we had
to do it how nervous were you making
this deal I'm nervous I'm still I'm
still a little still a little nervous
that it's going to work out but I'm
excited and I think it will but it's a
it's a big big train for the city for
our team we lost two of our kind of not
cornerstone pieces but pieces that were
homegrown and beloved in the locker room
and within the organization in the city
so taking a big risk here but when you
see that like are you waiting for a
phone call you know is that one of those
where you tell your friend hey do not
call me I'm waiting to see if we're
gonna pull off this Jimmy Butler deal
yes for two days it was I'll get back to
you tomorrow and I didn't hear back
something I'm like well do I call back
or do I seem now how many times were you
traded in your career I was traded from
the Bulls to the Clippers and I think
the rest of the time they either sign
free agency or was cut
how were you told my agent Davis Faulk
called me for the first one and he knew
before it happened it actually gave me a
few options like do you wanna go to the
Wizards or to LA because he you know
being a super agent that he is but yeah
so my agent told me first and we're
talking Elton Brand the 76ers GM and my
first reaction when you got Jimmy Butler
is what this meant for marquel folds
that I know that he had playing time I
don't know how much it's reduced now but
what's it mean for his role with this
team moving forward
yeah I mean it's going to be ripple
effects between though the whole squad
everybody's going to see the effects of
sport time all-star coming to your team
with minutes and roll and everything
like that but we're still going to try
to develop them is the best way we can
and I feel bad for Melton I know a lot
of this game everybody's got talent and
a lot of its mental but I I mean I was
heartbroken when I saw the free throws
that you know that it's gotten that bad
you know it's I don't know how you fix
it no no that's no part of my job is to
put them in environment and let's try to
find out ways to but you're right like
we were he's one of ours he's with us we
just have to find ways and do our best
to support a person or have you ever
seen something like this where somebody
gets the yips from the free-throw line
well I wouldn't call it the wide word
but no I haven't seen that yeah that
guys'll like their guys who you know
have nightmares that they lose their
shot or you know this happens in all
sports where you think I can't make I
mean it doesn't happen to me on but it
happens to you know other other shooters
in there a lot of lot of sports
especially at the professional level
with different pressure contracts and
things like that absolutely if you need
me to come in I can help I can put on a
shooting clinic if you want to is a
consultant I'd be more than happy to
help the 76ers free of charge yell you
just let me know okay
I appreciate that hey congrats and good
luck we always appreciate your time okay
sir it's a Elton Brent I think my
relationship with him goes back to his
freshman year Duke
I think it's that long that we've been
in touch with you for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
you
[Music]